or gad elmaleh ou gad elmaleh
[Applaudissements]
gad elmaleh au coeur des vallées
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gad elmaleh qui fait souvent créés en
voiture jusqu'au plateau c'est n'importe
quoi
pour pouvoir
[Applaudissements]
dans l'air du temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
soit versée mais cinq ans
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à cette 32ème
cérémonie des césar
voilà ce que je veux dire c'est que
voilà j'ai fait un pari sur twitter
c'était assez marrant et j'ai dit que je
resterai en de papillons pour tout les
vaisseaux à cirer là toute l'équipe
j'étais venu habillé comme ça pour
honorer cette première et et pour que ça
vous porte bonheur
[Applaudissements]
mais pas seulement comme une petite
danse pour toi également vous ne bougez
pas on se retrouve dans un instant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour la première date justement ports
insulaires civette rendez vous ce soir
et encore beaucoup beaucoup de choses
qui vont arriver gad elmaleh notre
jeannik nadal mal et j'ai envie de
danser
oui moi aussi moi aussi quand je te vois
j'ai envie dans ses réponses aux crises
et de faire la fête donnée donner de
l'argent à des familles de faire des
massages a déjà en train de faire du
bien autour de moi j'ai envie de chanter
genre ou gad elmaleh ou gad elmaleh
poker d'allemagne et ont quand même
aller
[Applaudissements]
mon ami m'a dit je te rappelle que je
m'appelle thierry beccaro
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hanouna
[Applaudissements]
donc
j'ai nagé juste devant le début dans la
presse alors chanté que les noms de
famille il a pas trouvé tout de suite tu
sais lui
pourquoi pas du tout est calé
[Musique]